¿Desde el primer momento en que abrió los ojos yo
estaba ahí soy alegría raíz es la viva imagen de
la alegría fue increíble bueno durante 33 segundos hoy triste
o
Hola podría a ver si arreglo es todo la central
se fue llenando a partir de ahí estoy detectando un
olor peligroso que es asco básicamente impide que realicen el
brócoli Believe lio? Elio este es miedo se le da
bien mantener a raya salvo el iOS son los recuerdos
de raíz fe y la mayoría le griega hecho algo
el recuerdo lleva todo bien bien supongo no ve los
esenciales griega.
¿Puedo decir esa palabrota helio por qué no funciona nadie
you huimos un problema alegría sabía qué hacer donde estamos
es la memoria a largo plazo esto se puede arreglar
solo tenemos que volver a la temprano puedes perder ahí
dentro se positiva vale sé positivamente que te vas a
perder Believe súper enorme?
¿Andrea el sueño traducción es unicornio eres tú estuviste genial
en cuentos de hadas parte 7 k Dios te adoro
griegos abrazo en grupo felise siempre se puede mejorar perlas
grivel iOS muerto es lo que yo llamo un éxito
total ni cumpleaños agriado alegría estuviera aquí?
Eliel.